wifi avant d'accepter de coucher avec
vous on va d'abord savoir ce que vous
seriez prête à faire par amour
[Applaudissements]
attention irène est ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous déguiser en
elton john fait on n'avait
qu'à
kehl oui oui vous êtes prête à vous
déguiser en même temps j'aime bien
c'est un coup l'un est ce que vous
seriez prête irène par amour à vous
droguez par amour citation extrême
vraiment vraiment vraiment extrême oui
en cas d ouais non est-ce que vous soyez
prêt et irène par amour à prendre 17 kg
oui en cas non qu'est way we had à ça
nous aide à choisir vous aussi c'est
bien pour nous c'est tournez manège
vraiment là
est-ce que par amour est-ce que par
amour elle me seriez prête à aller vivre
à limoges
5e pluton tu vas adorer
oui vous vous souvenez oui oui oui oui
oui oui démarche vous seriez dommage oui
bah oui je serai pas les moyens ou bien
où est ce que par amour irène vous
seriez prête à cacher quelqu'un qu'il
vient de tuer
alors il faut que je réfléchisse sur la
wii désaccord oui oui oui
par amour amour oui oui si je laime
c'est que la wii en cas kerouay non vous
savez maintenant est-ce que par un mot
et rennes vous seriez prête en brasse et
100 fois ses chaussettes sales
oui
salut je lui fais un livre
moi j'ai un faible pour irradier but des
pieds patrick vieira
est ce que par amour en cas vous seriez
printemps brasse et 100 fois ses
chaussettes sales question clotilde
courau la main qui ment des gammes en
deçà de faire l'amour
ah la la
kolélas sachant pas je me trouve mais
oui mais je t'aime pas
qu'est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à embrasser son choix
ces chaussettes sales alors cent fois
oui parce que je suis gélase une visite
alors c'est pas trop
bien est ce que par amour vous
accepteriez irène quelques petites
infidélités à son camp et non mais avec
moi il sera
ces constats l'appellation
fait pousser un peu la firme ksh
pts que par amour en cas vous
accepteriez quelques petites bio
fidélité moi j'aime dans les caisses que
gérer soir oui jamais une fille belle je
pense
que oui et bah bah écoutez si moi je
pense que enfin si c'est une seule fois
je peux parler
d'accord pour que c'est vraiment oui oui
celui là je le ferai mais deux fois ça
casse à accueillir deux fois non
monsieur ridicule deux fois
et quand on sait jamais si on goûte à
prix attention c'est beaucoup plus grave
maintenant ils renaissent que par amour
vous accepteriez de vivre à 3
non non non c'est sa chienne oui un
shérif
les soins
je suis là l'an passé
non c'est wasquehal ralentir au
quatrième comme un bébé enfin sans
coucher non car il pas d'accord et oui
non est-ce que par amour irène vous
accepteriez de fréquenter des clubs
échangistes alors une clope d'échangé
c'est quand tu fais quelque chose avec
plusieurs gens en même temps c'est ça
non c'est pas mon c'est parce que j'aime
faire non j'ai jamais fait je ne
m'attire pas ouais tu peux le voir
plusieurs fois qu'une personne
différente et comment vous savez pas
faire plusieurs fois avec la même
personne et comment vous savez que ça
vous plaît pas parce que vous avez
jamais se disent que j'ai jamais pensé
parce que quand je suis avec quelqu'un
j'aime bien moi je vous laisse plus
franche et explique à ses deux branches
- ses erreurs le haut
non moi c'est lui moi c'est le feu moi
c'est ça l'amour c'est la même chose
c'est sûr et le sable c'est le bon moi
c'est tout ça avec quelqu'un oui donc ça
me comble
enfin ça m'attire pas bien en cas les
clubs échangistes pourquoi pas par amour
en cas si tulle m6 replay 6 a lui même
saisi la nuit un matin
il y avait une très bonne tenue dans ce
débat
j'ai ouï les clubs échangistes pareil je
l'étais se partager taillan faire
l'amour avec son meilleur pote non pour
le faire plaisir
vous avez d'accord est-ce que par un mot
soyez prêtes tapotage hockey par aman je
serai prête à faire tout ça sur une
autre planète mais sur terre tu veux
dire irene est ce que vous seriez prêtre
par amour à devenir son esclave sexuelle
oui
bien sûr on commence en faisant partager
leur plaisir c
cnet uk school a discuté et ouais
par mots vous soyez prête à devenir son
esclave sexuelle
non par amour et rennes est ce que vous
seriez prête à changer de sexe
mais moi je m'aime moi je suis vous
n'avez pas eu le dessus tellement
tellement tellement une femme je
pourrais pas pris pour rire un petit peu
oui mais enfin on opérait
m aegon censure mais pas son but c'est
navrant car oui changer de sexe non ok
oui s'il provient de seconde
essayons si ça ne plaît pas tu meurs
donne
les canétois
et on les change de sexe changer de sexe
ou non lignum vannes non contente
maintenant on va perdre inverse
patrick bruel si vous deviez choisir une
des modèles ce laquelle prendriez michel
fils
patrick haas est très difficile et mon
idée mais moi je sais moi là moi aussi
moi aussi non mais c'est difficile c'est
pas un
jeu je trouve que cueillir elle a
quelque chose de très touchants dans sa
dépendance à dans sa vérité est très
passionné
l'astre avec oui c'est bien
ça devrait ça c'est tout est vrai ici il
ya hockey a fait ça sur une autre
planète exact dragon puis patrick quand
même ce serait plutôt iran mais
j'attends qu'il soit charmant tout les 3
5 ans qu'on dit c'est toi pape on attend
qu'on s'engage
l'échelle est d'après qui doit juni et
dans les coulisses je t'emmerde
julie n'était pas dans les coulisses
michel
avec un cadreur donc de
jean-luc irène ma fille
je me ferais une belle brochette de
couchage pour les trois mois
j'ai servi beaucoup vexé les 2 août mais
je prends aussi rennes
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus